coming up next are you are you upset
yeah I'm upset what are you upset about
what happened I don't know
tears dripping from my eyes
what's
what's the answer to that to get a man
to commit to you and to get a man to
sleep with you is different and those
qualities are different if you want the
guy to full on marry devote to you and
make you his one and only don't give
away what makes you valuable to men
there's a lot of people saying oh I love
my man I love my man
but for one reason or the other they're
the biggest holdback sometimes I want to
be with you but you know I don't really
I want to be around you so you could
just be in the air vent if the man is
the only one working I'm providing then
he she gets absolutely zero so because
it's the man's money and he's providing
you a house you it's like Beggars can't
be choosers sometimes he just wants to
bust a nut he's just he's stressed he
needs to release that energy and he's
gonna and the wife is his release so at
that point it needs to be on demand
because the guy has a build up he wants
to release it well I mean you can't like
I can't turn on the water faucet on
demand you know what I mean then give
head okay so today
um I have my Hefty dafty whiteboard out
and I specifically recruited men for
this show because I want to hear from
the men
what do you guys want from women what
should women that come to you bring to
the table so I'm going to get up
and you can start
for me personally it's more about a
degree of
personality traits alongside Beauty I
think the things what people have uh
what women think matter to Men actually
don't we don't care about your money we
don't care that you're independent we
don't care you are a quote-unquote boss
like no one cares about any of
that things especially if you want
something seriously I think the biggest
thing they don't understand is that
the to get a man to commit to you and to
get a man to sleep with you is different
and those qualities are different so if
a guy is just looking to sleep with a
woman
um certain long-term things he won't be
interested in
um so for me I would say
why what women need to bring or what I
would like them to bring per se is sort
of feminine energy submissive
non-argumentative
um kind
supportive these are the traits are
important to me anyway
foreign
for me personally I'd say
I would like in a serious relationship a
woman to bring loyalty is a big one for
me
um
and I'd also say
apart from loyalty another big one would
be
if I had to be virtuous
I'd say
but to be virtuous and what do you mean
by virtuous virtuous is
is not
in the sense of almost like a
that kind of
innocent feminine energy and
unwillingness to kind of
take leadership are you Christian uh no
I wouldn't cross myself have you heard
of Proverbs 31
I've heard of it I don't know what it is
that's why it's describing the ideal
wife I think it's proverbs 31 is
probably the best example of a virtuous
woman but as a it's intimidating yes but
yeah that's what women should strive to
be I would agree with you
yeah
so me do you do you date hoes
I knew it was coming I'm sorry
so me what I would like my woman to
bring to the table is loyalty I would
need my woman to be my friend because I
don't just want to be with someone
that's not that I don't get along with
and again like she would need to be
beautiful in a sense because I don't
just want to be looking at you and like
you don't like I'm not attracted to you
so that would be for me
well for me definitely you'd have to be
a virgin so virginity is the main thing
I'd say come you're born with value
don't give it away if you want the guy
to full on marry devote to you and make
you his one and only don't give away
what makes you valuable to men you're
born with a certain amount of value
based on your looks based on your purity
but even sometimes based on your family
status sometimes you're from a wealthy
family well-known family there's a lot
of things that go into it but yeah I'd
say the main things are definitely
submission you want you don't want
someone to argue against you you don't
want someone to be against you you want
to be the leader of your house you want
to be the leader of the relationship and
in order to do that you need someone
submissive loyalty is definitely there
because if she's not loyal no one's
going to be interested in her in the
first place unless you're you know a car
core a simple you know there's loads of
words to describe feminine definitely
because you know it's just you can't be
masculine and expect a masculine man
because a masculine man is going to want
someone feminine you can't be because
it's the same way of describing a man
who's part feminine
and like one day he wants to wear a mini
skirt or a dress that's not very
masculine is it it's like a woman saying
oh yeah I'm gonna wear the trousers and
go to work today it's just like that's
not feminine it's just it's not what men
want
men literally want feminine loyalty
submission Purity Beauty as well like
some men don't even expect that much
Beauty anymore they've actually got lost
as long as you're hitting the other
targets they're actually fine with
lowering what they perceive as their
level
as long as you hit everything else that
they want so that's what I'd say they
should actually bring to the table what
they've already got what they're born
with and then character traits that they
just develop over time if they're
actually following what they should be
following
um I want a woman that's Cooperative
again no one likes to argue all day
um a woman that's submissive
um she knows that I'm not being not
asking her to be submissive is not
against her it's all that everything
runs smoothly
um a woman as a team player that
understands that everything is for the
betterment of the collective not for
anyone's selfish interests and the woman
that's supportive kind
yeah that's that's about it
well uh if I'm just looking for a good
time then
none of what anyone here is
[Laughter]
um apart from you know you gotta look
good of course
but if it's um someone I'm gonna take
seriously
um you have to just not get in the way
of my work
you've got to
add
to my work ethic as in whatever you can
do whatever holes you can feel that I
may have that can help me
um do what I do better
uh you know help me in my kind of
my strive for more
my ambition
so just get behind me and support me
and be loyal
be in shape
and if you're not in shape then you must
have that
um as a goal you must be actively right
now be looking to get into shape
and
yeah just be you know just just be cool
like
you know all that loudness and where to
none of that just
be cool be feminine
are there any skills that you'd like
like what specific skills would you like
a girl to have
but it's cook would be nice okay what
what do you think girls should be able
to cook
um I don't think pasta counts I'll start
I think everyone is like I said I wanna
I wanna be wifey like what what should
she what should she start with what did
she learn to cook uh cultural food so
depending on what ethnicity she is I
think she should at least know the basic
the basic foods that our culture comes
from if I'm with someone Arab I expect
them for example Moroccan I expected
tonight to make tagine I expect it's an
hour to make the basic things that come
from that side of the world I'm sure if
I'm American I should know hamburgers
and hot dogs
there's brisket that's barbecue I've
seen American barbecue I know they're
like I'm sure like I know I know some
Jamaican guys that's like if my wife
can't make rice and peas I'm not even
gonna look at her so this is you know
it's just you need to be able to provide
the sustenance side and like the
nurturing side so you need to be able to
cook you need to be able to clean
because that is the main thing you're
going to be doing looks like you're
going to be taking care of children
what cleaning skills would you want you
get to build a wife today
want to get specific because a lot of
times when I hear what guys want from
girls it's very Broad and there's no
like specific things that girls can do
to like train to do these things and we
are opening a wife school soon so oh
well I think the reason sorry the reason
why there's no specific things is
because if there were those girls would
not give a anyway
okay well today we're doing a whiteboard
no we'll care if we're into you well I
mean there's women that they find
themselves like surprised they're you
know turning out their feminine side I
guess for the right guy they find
themselves on Google looking up how to
make French toast so so it happens but I
think yeah there has to be genuine
desire so if a woman if a woman is just
giving you a hard time about the things
that you like well she can kind of just
keep it pushing I think that's a fair
point and the ability to learn as well
even if you don't know how to do
anything the ability to learn to show is
how I personally would receive care I
would that to me that would show you
that you care about what I think what I
like to do what I like to eat Etc and
the ability to learn is half the battle
but with the attitude of oh I don't want
to do that why should I do that it's
it's just redundant isn't it yeah yeah
that's how I got married I didn't know
how to do anything any I have no no
model of like how to be a wife but I
brought a willingness to learn and so I
think that that just happened to be
enough well with results because I feel
like I feel like if I was slipping up
people say something so I think it
really just comes down to the basics of
knowing how to keep a house so if the
man's actually going out working working
his ass off trying to provide for the
family I think that it's the women's
actual duty to make sure the house is
clean the kids are taken care of he
doesn't want to come home to everyone
screaming he wants like the house to be
peace he wants to come home to peace
from chaos work is sometimes chaos I
describe work it's chaos sometimes so
he's going to come from chaos into Peace
So the whole point is everything needs
to be kept dinner ready and that's it
it's it's not that difficult like I'd
say that when you talk about cleaning
skills I'd say just like mop mop floor
make it so that when you enter the house
you take off your shoes so the house
stays clean like everyone people in the
house makes try their hardest to make
sure it doesn't get any dirtier but
obviously the wife's job is to clean if
it does get any dirty so dusting just
mopping you know vacuum cleaner yeah
even get a room by it does half the job
you're up for you but at the end of the
day the whole point is you just want to
come home to a nice clean nice smelling
house and I think to add on to the the
Peace point that you made I think a
woman should be like your spiritual
protector in a sense like you'll have
physical protector I feel like she needs
to be able to like Spirit spiritually
protect you and ground you because the
world is almost can be chaotic and when
you come home you want her to be able to
ground you and you want her to be able
to make you feel at peace if that makes
sense and that goes back to our point
about we don't want someone
argumentative yeah destructive those
things don't bring peace and ironically
what happens is if you are with a woman
like that and she behaves like that
that's just in all honesty it just gives
a man more reason to cheat because he's
just gonna go somewhere and build up
peace understanding you know good
listening skills from another woman and
she's going to set your place so how how
can a woman keep you grounded because I
think I think I struggle with that I
think you know my husband comes home he
can be pretty stressed out from work
because like you said work is chaos so
I'm like well like what do I do do I hug
him do I leave him alone I think he's
the leave him alone give uh let him play
video games kind of Route so like how
can a woman be grounding to you guys
what's what would peace look like she
could do it oh okay
it's that simple it just comes down to
silence and then just doing the things
that she normally would do for you
taking care of you sitting next to you
like just you know peace peace generally
is seen as silence if you're in peace if
you're in you know people say Zen it is
pure silence the guy wants to come home
to a nice quiet home most of the time he
doesn't want to come home to chaos and
he says normally described as silence
okay
that for me I think the Deep obviously
loyally and cooperative and the friend
and feminine are all key things but I
think the most important thing is deep
understanding now there's levels of
understanding and I think with
understanding comes trust so if you get
to know the man and you really want to
fulfill your man and want to see him win
then you're going to let him lead and I
think a lot of it boils down to trust
there's a lot of people saying oh I love
my man I love my man
but for one reason or the other they're
the biggest holdback sometimes so I
think that men I think men realize when
a girl genuinely
wants to see him win not just for her
benefit and for me I think that's the
that's the key thing and then with that
when a female's trusting you comes
femininity a lot of men are thinking oh
why is my girl masculine because she's
not trusted you so I think that's what I
think that's what it boils down to so I
hear that I hear where you say it you
wanna you wanna come home and you want
silence and peace
but now if she's silent it could be a
bit of a problem she can talk about it
well that's what I was saying is like
what if you're coming home and uh you're
stressed or you're feeling down what if
you want to like you want I know
something encouraging what would that
look like because one of my girlfriends
has told me that when her man is
stressed out that she just gives him a
big hug so I think I was looking for
like those kind of actions obviously you
know being quiet in the midst of chaos
is helpful
that's what I think too because a lot of
times when guys say what they want it it
sounds really simple which okay and but
it's very Broad and so it's like if you
were gonna say to someone all right I
want to be a wife how do I become one
like what would you tell them to do go
ahead let me is it Aliyah oh yes so I
can't speak for all men I can't speak
for your your husband however
I can tell you about me so if I came
back from work and I was stressed
all my other half would have to do
if I had one would be
nothing
like silence
chill
okay um
there's not even that much pressure on
you to to
um yeah like just have something ready
for us to eat together
yeah
um and then just chill
let me you don't need to ground me or
anything like that like I've been
grouting myself for 35 years I'm very
very good at grounding myself and all
the rest of it just don't don't add to
the stress yeah that's that's it okay
that's an action a lot of girls a lot of
girls I'm not saying all girls a lot of
girls somehow still find a way to just
not be able to do nothing they they find
a way to wanna add to the stress it's
like they've been waiting for you to
come home all day just to tell you
something you have to get on your nerves
you know sometimes it's like all right a
man's just happy just to see you like
just just be just exist and be feminine
so I can give you my full masculine but
if you're acting frantic and all
masculine how can you expect me to be
masculine well you know it's not it's
not like that so like I stay home
um and then so my husband's gone like 10
to 12 hours a day and you know when I
see him I just get so excited I'm like
oh my God I can't wait to tell you about
my day and he's like 30 minutes an hour
30 minutes an hour and I'm ready to hear
about your day so like we don't we don't
we're not trying to add to your plate
but I see your point so it's called a
decompression time is what a lot of
counselors call it apparently men need
that I feel like I don't think women are
like that I don't feel like I need not
even like five minutes to myself no
because we're more social so to us like
when we come home we're excited to talk
to each other but men aren't like that
they're like Get Away have you ever seen
that have you ever seen that Chris Rock
I think it's Chris Rock where he's like
we like you there but not there okay
I want to be with you but you know I
don't really I want to be around you so
you could just be in the air vent that's
what Patrice O'Neill said oh God no I
was going to say I think as men I think
we're very self-aware in the sense that
how we want to make sure that we receive
our woman properly so sometimes we may
need like half an hour to just to
decompress but I think sometimes women
take offense of that when they say give
me like 30 minutes
why are you mad at me
it's like it's not about you babe it's
me just give me 30 minutes that's a hard
concept for them to grab that it's not
about them because they always think
it's about them but that's why you get
guys sort of sitting in the car when
they get back from work for about 10
minutes just to have a moment to
themselves to go into the house because
hey it's like you know I don't mean this
disrespectfully but you know when you
have a puppy and they run to the door
when you come through the door it's a
bit like that it's nice it's nice it's
not supposed to be of course
disrespectful but it's like the
excitement to see you it is lovely but
like you said you need to just five
minutes just let me just chill for two
secs I mean I'd actually also add it it
depends on your current like position in
the relationship so what what like if
you're in the honeymoon period I'd say
it's a lot more romantic and full-on and
more sexually driven at that point in
the first like six months of normal
relationships a lot of sex happens so in
that case the man would be anticipating
that as soon as he gets home if I was
married I'd expect some form of intimacy
as soon as I get home if it was the
first but obviously let's say 10 years
down the line if I'm working and if
things are chailed together can I get
home I'm just going to want to relax I'm
just going to want to sit decompress as
you've said and then eventually after a
while maybe have dinner and then during
dinner start conversation and then keep
a conversation going overnight but the
whole point is you need men need that
decompression when they get home if
they're not because the thing is men the
thing is if it's not the honeymoon
period and it's not a part where he's
very sexually driven and he can't wait
to get home to literally rail you
against the bed then you literally need
the position off he needs peace he needs
to relax for a bit because if he doesn't
get that he's just gonna build up even
more stress and it's going to get
bottled and he might explode and you
know and some men explode in different
ways and then yeah I'd say that's the
main that's the Crux of the situation
yeah I think I think the main thing I
can speak for all men I think all men
want respect
definitely it was I think it boils down
to respect when a man is disrespected he
can do crazy things let's be honest I
think disrespect even leads men to
cheating which never really wants to get
spoken about it's always this guy's a
bad guy for cheating but let's ask
ourselves how many times how many times
did you disrespect your man before he
cheated that's like every single like
school shooter story I've ever heard
yeah I mean we we want respect from men
let alone our women you know what I mean
like respect is number one be Beyond
love beyond beyond anything respect is
one and then well a woman has to respect
you in order to love you in the first
place it starts with respect I think I
think without respect it doesn't work it
cannot work if the girl actually wants
she's gonna have to get to the point
where she has to respect you or she has
to find someone she does respect yeah
the relationship doesn't work without
respect otherwise you get a lot of
problems just developing and actually
growing it's like a seed if you if
there's no respect it's gonna grow yeah
it's gonna literally grow and ruin
things and it gets ruined in different
ways so you guys you guys know why we
disrespect you guys right okay this
looks like for the for the women that
love you that get out of pocket okay
because there's just like some naturally
psychotic women that's like she's just
gonna be out of pocket for everyone so
the way uh there's a doctor his name is
Dr egrets he talks about love and
respect right and it's in the Bible too
where women are commanded to respect
their husbands and husbands are
commanded to love their wives right and
there's a reason for that and so when
when I feel unloved we tend to get
disrespectful and then if you feel like
I'm disrespecting you you're gonna go
out of your way to make sure that I
don't feel loved and you're not going to
cuddle with me and it goes into this
cycle and you never know when to hop off
because it's like well do I want to hop
off no he should hop off when really
it's like once you know you're in the
cycle you should just hop off just for
the greater good whoever figures it out
first so yeah I think that that's a
that's a common thing because
um when men blow up nobody ever asked
what did she say and I feel like we
should start asking because it's really
good it's mad because they always if if
a girl blows up it's what did he do yeah
yeah but we never asked what did she say
and so many times that one oh well what
did you do what did you do it's not
about me I'm not a narcissist it's about
it's true we have to and we have to
remember as well it's respect isn't just
in the home when we're outside your
females representing you if she's
representing you in a mad way she's not
respecting you so I think you're such a
360 thing yeah you've got like obviously
when you come home from work but on the
flip side you've got how she's
representing you outside if she if your
girl does not respect and rate you
you hear him know about it and it will
burn but girl a girl asked me the other
day ago that I'm talking to and um she
said to me
um so babes like how would you want me
to be like say we were a thing like I
would you know and I said to uh I want
you to pretend you're always wearing a
permanent T-shirt with my face on it so
you know no matter where you are you
you're wearing a t-shirt and it's got my
face on it
and and that's the mindset that you need
to have because when they've when
they've got that in their mind
they're acting it out there's no it's
like a constant romance yeah exactly
what what are some ways that a woman can
demonstrate respect because again like
respect very Broad and we ain't got no
doubt he's just like y'all don't got
daddies so what how can we demonstrate
by listening just look out in there I do
think that like a good woman's gonna
test you as a man I don't think there
should be like unrealist unrealistic
expectation that a woman's not going to
test you and it's good because as a man
you need to be on your A game so a good
woman's gonna test you and you need to
be like the best version of yourself to
be able to deal with that and kind of
make her fit into your frame just to add
that in I have to disagree with that one
uh yeah I was gonna say I completely
disagree I think respect is when she
doesn't do that like she respects
disrespects you by the way no no I'm
saying that she shouldn't even test you
like the whole point is when someone
respects you you don't like you don't
test your boss you don't go to your boss
and start testing them testing them
like oh what about this what about that
like at the end of the day it is the
kind of Boss Dynamic like at the end of
the day a relationship is you go to work
every day like I'm just like it's just
it's really simple it sounds it's people
complicate it a lot but when it comes to
respect just listen to what the man says
at the end of the day he has the final
say if you're in a dynamic relationship
where it's masculine feminine the man
has the final say and the Crux of it
really does literally come down to list
listening respect not arguing
understanding that he has the final say
and that's literally how it should be
sort of boil it down
she has to listen yeah listen that's
actionable items whatever the man says
does do so she listens yeah yeah okay
and you know what not to not to
disrespect my brother here or anybody
else solar panel but no tests yeah
because
you might be you might be right but in
my in my world it's not unrealistic
because listen I'm tested every day yeah
up at 6am working from eight till nine
most days seven days a week no tests
that's enough if you test to become part
of the problem I I don't I don't think
that I don't think I know a single wife
that doesn't test their husband now I
think there are malicious ways to test
your husband I think that's true but
there's other ways that you're going to
be tested so like example you know
fatherhood that's that's a test is to
see like you know how do you perform as
a father and a husband I don't think
you're going to be able to get away from
it and so I live in the Midwest and so
there's a feminine wise masculine
husbands in the church husbands are
providers protectors women are feminine
submissive but there there are still
going to be tests like you still want
your boundaries respected as a human
being and an individual I understand
what you're saying like don't be
malicious about it but I think it's
unrealistic to think that you know that
it's not going to happen at all so I'm
thinking I'm just going with that train
of thought I don't I don't really have
an opinion on this but I'm going with
that train of thought do employees test
bosses ever
yes they do because you kind of see what
you can get away with right I'm thinking
more test like do something
disrespect like there's respectful ways
of testing there's passive ways of
testing like for example you brought up
the have children that's a passive way
that's gonna happen that's not you can
see that and it's not a direct test to
the man it's just like the man's gonna
provide and you're going to see what
he's like how he's going to take care of
the child how he's going to take care of
you so a question should and this is
just genuine question should a woman if
you tell her something and it's not
something that she agrees with how
should she go about it because at some
point there's going to be something that
you tell her that she disagrees with and
ask me an example otherwise because
there's so many different things that
would be so
um
oh you got one I have one so you and
this is something common that I've like
older Generations you want to buy a
house
she thinks you're being too Reckless
with the money
she gets absolutely zero so zero say
zero say when the man has earned all
that money and she's it depends on the
dynamic if the man is the only one
working I'm providing then he she gets
absolutely zero so because it's the
man's money and he's providing you a
house you it's like Beggars can't be
choosers right I know that's the wrong
technology most girls have to work in
2022. I don't know I'm talking about
Dynamic with a man don't where the woman
doesn't work obviously if the woman 2022
so most girls have to work like she has
to help pay the mortgage my my opinion
no I don't really have an opinion I'm
just trying to figure out okay so in
that case I wouldn't I wouldn't like be
happy with that at all but if someone
was in a situation where the woman was
also earning and she was also
contributing then definitely however
much I believe it should be very static
so however much he contributes is how
much say she has so if the man earns 70
and she earns 30 I believe she should
have a 30 Same by that logic if a girl
earns more than a guy she should have
the final say yes but I also don't agree
with the woman working if it wants to be
a dynamic the man and woman in our
masculine feminine okay well yeah I mean
that's the ideal right I think most
girls would like to be Housewives but
again we're in 2022. I think lower the
standards I think living standards okay
go ahead the key thing is yeah you're
we're 20 22 going into 2023. we can't be
we've got to always look at it and I
think just looking at that the no tests
feel like genuine like generally
if the female has the respect levels
that she should have for you and she's
going for the type of man
that she a genuine King then the testing
is not really going to happen and going
on to that the the split so talking
about like the property with things
if if the female's earning of course it
makes sense to communicate on on the
trace to say that ah do you know what
I'm gonna make a choice you're gonna
have problems in 10 years and she's just
gonna bottle things up you're asking for
a problem it's about genuinely you have
to
communicate well with each other hear
each other's voice
and because it's different now the
percentage when the man's earning all of
the money is is it's not really
happening like that females generally
are working they're earning money
they're doing projects however she can
be earning the same amount but if she
really has trust in you she's going to
let you naturally lead with a decision
the problem is there's a lot of men
earning the same or a little bit less
than the female of course the female's
not going to trust the man because a lot
of these a lot of these males out here I
don't even trust them myself so like
they can't they can't manage their own
money in that Dynamic the woman actually
has more so because that woman normally
is in control of the sex in the marriage
and if the man doesn't do what she wants
she's gonna it's gonna become a secless
marriage but then she's the she's the
masculine one yeah that's what happened
that's what happened yeah she deserves
that I can't I can't speak yeah that's
why I personally wouldn't want someone
who's working I would want my wife to be
a full-on stay-at-home wife so and
that's how I avoid that that situation
that you just brought up uh what if
she's working and then she wants to
contribute and then she gets to say in
my opinion it should be the man's the
only one dealing with the money and
financial side it's just it's just like
nowadays idealistic you know what I
think the whole idea of there being no
test sounds great but the purpose of a
test is to prove how competent someone
is so if she's constantly testing you
she's trying to show how competent you
are and let's be honest you can never
you can never get too comfortable so I
think passive testing is good but I
don't think direct testing is good at
all yeah I think I think it's intent
like what's your intent is it to make
your man feel small or is it to be like
okay how is this leadership because I
mean I I'm a self-aware woman I don't
again I don't know a single wife that
wasn't that doesn't test her man but
mine is the only the only ish test that
I have left that I even do and it I
think at this point in time I like I
think it might just be out of habit but
the one thing I'll do is like I'll be
thinking in my head I'm like ah I want a
glass of water but I don't want to get
out of bed I'm like okay all right let
me see if he's gonna say yes because he
might he might not and so I'll ask my
husband like hey can you give me a glass
of water and sometimes he'll look at me
for like three to five seconds and he's
like I kind of I think you can get that
yourself and I'm like okay this man
knows I'm capping he knows I'm capping
yeah yeah but it's good because if you
can fold to me you'll fold to the world
right so I just I need to know that you
can stand up to me because I'm not
always going to be able to lead myself
like women I I'm gonna like confess it
yeah like we're emotional and we're
hormonal in many ways and so like if
we're because I'm also pregnant right
now and so that first trimester I'm like
I need a man to guide me because I don't
know where I'm taking myself at this
point in time but you guys were talking
about the house that actually happened
to me
um my my husband he fell in love with
the house and he's very much if you find
something he likes that's what he's
gonna get and I was worried about it
because it was a little bit it was a
little bit expensive okay uh and so I
mean he did ask for my input though but
I do give the the big life decisions I
just give it to my husband because I
don't I don't want that responsibility
on my shoulders I'm just being real but
um so we just looked at it and it was a
risk and I was like well do you think
that you know we can pull it off because
I know that my husband's also willing to
have accountability for a negative
outcome and he's like yeah well it's a
risk but I think we can swing it I think
we can pull it off and at the end of the
day we did end up uh being able to do it
so he he guessed right and nothing bad
happened and for women that are watching
even if your man fails sometimes he's a
human being like he's not going to get
100 right all the time you gotta at
least be nice about it because as wives
like we make mistakes too often often
probably more but I don't think it's
difficult do you get as a wife you get a
lot of benefit of his decision so that's
why he takes a risk of doing the bigger
decision because I can't for me I can't
if I followed everything my wife did I'd
be in debt I couldn't afford I'd be in
situations like I'd be in this like that
but it's up to me to say no I'm gonna do
what's best for us and you're and you're
just gonna have to get on board with
because whatever you do like you said
about the money if he's buying a house
he's not living in there by himself like
he's living in there with his wife his
children so it's only going to benefit
them so it's like when we speak about
money in general if a man earns more
money than a woman usually the woman
gets all the benefit of that and that's
not a negative thing he actually puts
you in a better position his way of
thinking is that if I can work harder
and make more money she might not have
to work as much she might not have to
work at all she could be at home with
our kids it's all in the benefit of your
of your significant other right but if
we it was to flip it and women are like
oh I'm gonna earn all this money now
they think okay I don't need someone
because I earn this money so it never
benefits the man so whenever we have a
conversation about money of oh I earn a
certain amount of money as a woman and
that factors into their attraction it
doesn't because it doesn't benefit the
man the same way a man with that amount
of money whatever high amount you
imagine that to be would benefit his
woman and his kids so I don't even need
to speak anymore I have a question for
the man out of this list that we have um
there's two things that I'm surprised
none of you said I'm gonna curious if
either of you put it on
really quick if you guess there's two
I'm surprised no no one's sad wait no
previous kids beauty feminine virtuous
uh friend team player knows how to keep
a house submissive loyal Cooperative
ability to learn silence knows how to
mop dust vacuum virgin ideally cultural
food and in shape there's two things I'm
surprised no one put
I think somebody said it earlier I think
I might have heard one someone said no
previous kids oh no kidding no that's
part of Virgin isn't it
yeah but you can't find it there's no
virgin man I don't know if well maybe
you all are requiring me I don't know I
know you're definitely requiring you're
requiring
no one put sex
oh I mean I mean that's what comes under
submissive I think oh what do you mean
what I was a given yeah yeah I wanted
for marriages are sexless that's true
you guys think it's implied for some
reason women do not think it's implied
but we feel like it's implied that you
have to pay those bills every month so I
just think there's a miscommunication
and good with kids no oh yeah or
anything good with kids
okay so out of this list which one do
modern women struggle the most with oh
submissive and virginity I'd say those
are the ones they struggle with the most
well it'll be like virginity and then
I'll put no sex
um okay what it's a different one
Cooperative Cooperative feminine so if
you were gonna give a lesson on being
cooperative what would you say it's not
all about you that's that's where we
start it's not all about you like a
woman's world at all I think a lot of
women tend to Center themselves and make
everything about them when it's not
about them and I think it's hard to have
a conversation at that point to fall on
to that point as well they live in their
own reality their reality is their
reality we live in the real world like
we're real real world problems real
world interactions but they live in
their own reality that's why they only
see things through their lens they don't
see things through Islands as well nice
because women live in their feelings
whereas men are always based on logic so
that's that's what the end of the day so
so what would you tell her don't argue
don't raise your voice to me I I mean
I've been with my wife like six years
and she's never raised a voice to me
even if someone's messaging some
somewhere and it can sound like they've
got bass in their voice I'm like you
need to take that bass out of your voice
my guy take the base out of your face
I think you have to I think you have to
let her know that I'm not your enemy
because women are very neurotic and they
are designed to see men as a threat so
yeah I'm not your enemy and then with
that with that comes when you know when
they start being defensive yeah that's
that's what comes that's what comes with
that as well and he's not your equal
that's the other thing
but I think a few times I mentioned
about um understanding and I think we're
in a day and age now we're not expecting
every girl to be a virgin
it may be unfortunate maybe but I think
just being like understandings that fact
I think they don't really
want the ability to like you're saying
understand we've been we've been told so
much all the time it's about as long as
the woman's happy happy wife happy life
like divorces only happen if the wife's
unhappy I think a big part of the
unhappiness is just feeling not heard or
not understood and there's there's only
so much that you can do because if I'm
just a crazy lady and I never feel heard
or understood like you know that's
different but if you're actually doing
some form of communication that I'm like
this man is not considering me at all
then yeah okay that's fair listen listen
I was chilling with a girl once that I
was seeing yeah
this girl started crying
we were sitting we were sitting in my
flat she started crying I said babe
what's wrong
she said I don't know
that's a good answer I said I said no
like what's wrong what do you mean what
what happened
she said I don't know I said why are you
crying she said I don't know
are you are you upset yeah I'm upset
what are you upset about what happened I
don't know
tears different from us
warm up
what's
what's the answer to that well I mean
okay so a lot of women
um like they can't even say I don't know
right so I that's actually pretty
self-aware for her to be like look I
don't have a reason right because I mean
you you guys have probably experienced
it like sometimes we get mad and has
nothing to do with you I've had
experiences like that where you know I
go to my husband I'm like I'm upset with
you I don't know why there's no reason
for it I'm in my feelings and he's like
all right I got it so I think that's
better than nothing how did you guys
respond to something like that um
I think I think I think your situation
where you're speaking about your husband
versus your situation it wasn't
that relationship that's why it hit you
difficult yo listen even if it was my
wife I'd still I'd be as baffled because
there's something going on here and I
don't know what to do you don't even
know there's no point as an assistant oh
you want to fix it yeah you can't fix it
you don't know the thing that's
bothering you so I just have to sit here
and watch you in tears and we don't we
don't know why the tears are happening
actually Yes actually yes you just like
yeah you sit there and watch me cry as
long as you can take it and if you got a
time limit you got a timeline my husband
will give me 30 minutes
I think as men yeah
I said to her not in a rude way I was
just like
you've been here for three days maybe
maybe
um you just need to you you need a break
so why was she there for three times
we've seen each other but that's that's
the point that's the point of saying
though if it's your wife for five years
example sadly she's in her feelings
where's she going
but no but that's what I'm but that's
what I meant when I was that's what I
meant when I was saying about that the
difference right differentiation in
terms of like your wife
now yeah it's not ideal but we gotta
deal with this but when it's that
it's a uber you know what I mean so it's
different it's a difference I don't
think he really wanted her like long
term like you say you're seeing each
other but it's like she's there for
three days she starts crying you're like
goodbye so I feel like you we weren't
really into it now if that was a woman
you wanted to wife up I feel like you
might have been a little bit more
patient no
if if something's happening around me
and there's no logical explanation I'm
gonna be just as confused
it doesn't matter whether it's a wife a
day it doesn't matter
the confusion like I don't know what to
do with that you know what as well yeah
I think some men don't understand women
in a sense of they just want to feel
things
so where she just emotional and there's
just no
like explanation for it they just want
to feel it and US looking for a solution
is sort of getting them out of that
feminine thing because the feminine
energy is naturally chaotic and
confusing we're very logical as men and
women are very emotional so it does
conflict when you try and fix the
problem because there might not even be
a problem she might just be thinking
there's a problem when she can't
actually articulate what the problem is
or she can't actually imagine what the
problem is so she might actually just be
crying for things that she's feeling but
she doesn't actually know what the
problem is at all in those type of
situations I think it was Pro it will
probably be best just to leave her alone
just yeah do a thing Let Her Cry Now
have a moment after she's had her what
half an hour to cry then be like all
right cool let's go do something else
you take her mind off whatever it is and
then boom she's not upset no more to the
ladies yeah do you actually um based on
what we've just said do you actually
want solution oriented men
maybe to a degree because I mean I don't
I'm I am aware if I'm crying about
something and it's just my feelings and
I can say that and then if I want an
actual solution you know I have to
articulate that to my husband like
that's on me you know I need to tell you
I just want to feel heard right now or
okay I want to feel hurt also I need to
fix this problem and then he'll give you
Solutions but um it kind of gets in the
way uh because you don't necessarily
want your man to be your therapist your
therapist's supposed to you know solve
your your emotional feelings and things
like that but you just wanna you wanna
have somebody that cares that you're in
pain I think that's that's most of it
but I think women don't understand that
it is quite painful for a man to see the
woman that he cares about crying because
you can't you're helpless you can't do
anything about it
um but you know we there's some things
that we just can't help hormones are
really really strong and it's not an
excuse to have bad behavior but it is to
let you guys know like that's our
reality right and I've been finding out
a lot just being pregnant is absolutely
well your your wife is pregnant too
what's it been like my guy what's it
been like yeah she hasn't gone too too
crazy yet now she's starting to get a
little bit crazy yeah yeah I've got I've
got to add to the board as well
understand that men cannot read your
mind yes you have to articulate yourself
it's its own thing you know okay okay
not mind readers I put it as a I'll put
it on the other side because these are
the action items a lot of the time the
women think that men should be able to
read their mind like if they're upset or
if they're hungry they expect their man
to know but it's like how do you
expect me to know how the do you
expect me to know that I can start
throwing things like you you hungry you
want some flowers have you guys ever
been on road trips with women yeah yeah
have you have you ever noticed that uh
and I don't know this might not be true
for everyone we'll ask if you have to go
to the bathroom because we have to go to
the bathroom
yeah yeah okay not so much I'm sorry
just to answer Paul's question because
she as a man like what'd you do in that
situation I think as a guy you'll kind
of role is supposed to be I got this um
analogy from Jay Waller shout out to him
but you're supposed to be that um clip
or that Boulder and her waves of emotion
just crash into that and you just kind
of subdue it if that makes sense yeah
yeah that made me feel warm and fuzzy
inside I feel like that's correct yeah
okay what about oh man that broke
um what about sex how often do you guys
expect sex actually let's hear from the
the married guy how often do you expect
sex
y because because a lot of people have
these ideas in relationships and it's
different than marriage so I'm curious
from your point of view
to me and this is gonna sound a bit wild
but I just don't ever don't ever expect
her to say no if I want to have sex that
is the deal that we've made as being
married and you don't want me to do with
anyone else then that's what I should do
and that seems to work literally on
demand is what I'd say on request I'm
not sure with this one because after
I've seen a girl for a while it tends to
be her who's always winning it and I'm a
bit like oh I don't want to be like
there's a reason oh that means that
she's attracted to you that's good
there's a reason for that though because
scientifically men sex drive declined as
they age where it is women's increases
at the age yeah but it's not it's not
like my sex drive as a client it's just
like imagine you as a guy like how many
times a day do you really want to like
have sex it's not me it's it's not only
not only it's not just that that that's
a that is a fact but it's not just that
it's also once you've hit it
and then you hit it again
it starts to you know what I'm saying
that's what I was gonna say about the
variety so do you think variety plays an
aspect of that as well um no because you
can still be into the girl but it's just
that that energy thing like because for
me sometimes I don't even want to like
not join sex because I want to retain
that energy so it's just like oh we have
to go again and I have to like use up
energy and potentially gonna if I have a
bus I haven't had sex
I think it actually just comes down to
the guy sometimes he just wants to bust
a nut he's just he's stressed he needs
to release that energy and he's gonna
and the wife is his release so at that
point it needs to be on demand because
the guy has a build up he wants to
release it well I mean you can't like I
can't turn on the water faucet on demand
you know what I mean then give head okay
I feel like I feel that Pearl you're
pushing towards how many times a day
versus how many days in a week do you
know what I mean no I'm just saying like
okay she's in a way your employee right
now there's this much that there's like
a minimum amount of work required yeah
what would you I what would you expect
I would say there's no maximum and
there's no minimum it's what he said
just never say no never say no just
never say no if we're in a relationship
or we're married and if you want to have
it then I won't say no to you if if I
wouldn't have it then you don't say no
to me it's just it's fair that way well
I think Sex Drive is like very very by
men I know men have a higher sex drive
than women for sure just because of
testosterone levels we have like 117th
all the way to like 175th of like what
you guys have some of the time like some
men they want it you know three times a
day and then other men they want it a
couple times a week and I also think
that that honeymoon period you just want
to do it all the time on both sides
right so I think it depends on the guys
the question differently so we're in
wife's School we're saying that this is
what you should expect how often should
you expect to have sex in a relationship
at a minimum one to three times a week
that's a healthy marriage it sounds like
it three times a week minimum three
times a week be prepared for at least
once a day I'd say okay
when we're saying one to three times a
week we're talking individual actions
like
so that could be like once on a Monday
once on a Wednesday and once on a Friday
and that's a that's a good amount is
that what we're saying I'm asking um I
know you can say one to three times a
week is a is a standard marriage
I don't think that's a standard marriage
that's a healthy marriage
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible